I was just thinking today when you go
home
sit in a car for an extra two or three
seconds
and take
two or three big deep breaths
and then right before you get to the
front door or to the back door to the
garage door however you get into your
house
before you open the door
pull your shoulders all the way down
put a smile on your face because the
people inside that house
had nothing to do with why your day was
chaotic with your idiot boss in your
last meeting or the traffic on the way
home
and when you put a smile on your face
and you drop your shoulders you bring
warmth into that house not chaos
one of the greatest gifts you can bring
into your home is warmth
not rage not chaos not anger warmth
put a smile on your face tell the first
person you see I'm so happy to see you
you may freak them out but you may make
them smile too